hey guys it's Gianna here so I've put
together five of my favorite and really
effective exercises to give you a tonal
looking like perky butt and also tight
abs so there will be five exercises and
each workout will be for 45 seconds long
with 15 seconds rest in between and we
want to aim is to complete two sets okay
so it will be explosive you will be
burning lots of fat and you will also be
building lean muscles so get your body
warmed up and give it your best shot
so guys I want you to give me your best
effort okay there will be a lot of
jumping movements if you don't feel
comfortable jumping you can always
choose the low-impact option and just do
the squats all right we have 15 seconds
left and the first workout will be jump
squat with three pulses okay so I want
you to start by standing shoulder width
apart toes pointed forward
remember to really push your butt back
it gives me a nice jump and three small
pulses okay let's go up jump
three small pulses good jump and pop so
this workout it's really good to bring
those fats from your thighs your butt
and really to just turn them up okay at
night so shut up and small pulses if you
do know what the job you can just get up
into a squat and three small powers okay
and as you progress then explode into a
nice big jump nice remember to blend
gently on your feet and remember to keep
your knees then okay ten more seconds up
pulse up pulse now two more up pulse and
one more up and pop restaurant next
workout will be a reverse lunge with a
knee up or a hub okay so I want you to
stand
face forward take your step back get
into a reverse lunge and you can choose
to have your knee up or into a half
let's go lunch and half okay to keep
your balance
look straight ahead tighten your core
and really feel that right bomb working
and your right leg as well okay
and hard to really feel the right side
the right quad and the right thumb
working nice small hop but you should
really feel those muscles burning good
so look straight ahead
happy record and ha nice if you do not
want to you can just bring your knee up
okay lunge back bring your knee up
choose your option and slowly progress
and rest it out next workout has to get
down onto the floor into a frog okay so
I want you to start on a high plank and
you can choose to step in and step out
or you can choose to hop in and hop out
okay so choose your option keep your
hands on the floor throughout and look
straight ahead absolute straight and
back so into a nice deep Frogger keep
your legs apart and together good
tighten those core
pop and look up pop and look at good
keep going few more pacer breathing in
and out
whew nice one you should feel your upper
body working at the same time your legs
should be on fire
few more last one back and press it out
okay next workout all for closing cakes
so I want you to start on awful okay
knees on the floor arms on the floor I
want you to lift your knees up let's
start on the left side I'm going to
bring your knees in kick back to your
glutes working in and kick back okay
bring it in kick back and in and kick
back so slow controlled movement kick
back
nice in if this is difficult Guinness
you can start by having your right knee
on the floor and just bring your left
knee
kick back and really squeeze and feel
your butt muscles working very very good
so kick back and that's you slowly
progress then bring your right knee up
in kick back squeeze the butt those butt
muscles and kick back one last workout
and then we will get a one-minute break
okay so just lie down what we want to do
is hit bridge alright so again I will be
giving you options the easier option
will be to bring your tips of the floor
bring it down before it touches the
floor bring it back up and squeeze your
gluts okay so this is the easier option
good up and squeeze holy for two towels
back down and up if you want to
challenge yourself then what you can do
is to lift your right leg off the floor
and do single leg hip bridge and really
work on one side okay imagine that the
string pulling your belly button up and
really squeeze those glute muscles good
hence biocide up squid
bring it back down squeeze up and wrap
it out ah well done so take a shot one
minute break okay keep yourself hydrated
drink some water wipe your sweat and we
want to get into the second set all
right and we want to repeat all the
exercises again so grab some water and
keep us up hydrated
[Music]
right guys we want to get straight into
the second set okay we have about 20
seconds left
okay so give your legs some nice pad
okay with your muscles up and you know
all the workouts so I want you to try to
push yourself and really kiss your best
asset okay so the first workout will be
a jump squat with three pulses if you
want to you can always do a squat first
without the jumping so let's get into it
squat and three pulses nice okay or jump
up with three pulses good choose your
options nice
remember everybody has to start
somewhere and you slowly progressed from
that okay so if you can give five John
squats and then if you want to just not
slow and get into a squat brisk night
really push through your heels and then
gently good three pulses more pulses up
good do more up last one and up and just
rest it out next
reverse lunge with a hop so we started
on our right leg now let's get on to the
left side okay so take your right leg
back and bring your knee up
alright three seconds left give it a
good shake let's go right leg back and
bring your knee up okay
back and bring your knee up or if you
want to get into a nice deep hop kit
again
in order to find your balance look
straight ahead
tighten your core and really feel that
left leg working feel those sides those
but whoops breathe in and out in and out
good small hop is good enough to really
increase the intensity nice keep going
guys you're doing good
five more seconds three more last one
and rest it out
Prager let's get down onto a high plank
okay so again choose your variation you
can always start by bringing your leg in
and take a step back all right let's go
keep your hands on the floor don't keep
a body straight into a plank pop in body
strip to your app legs and back that is
the focus of the workout today back
pace yourself hook in out breathe in and
out nice keep your knees off do not lock
your knees okay if you can't see your
sweat dripping well that is your fat
crying when you're doing a good job keep
going oh I am naked but I'm feeling
strong one last one
whoo and rap it out all right next all
for floating kicks so we started on our
right pictures now now we want to move
onto our left side okay so keep your
left knee up all right kick and bring it
in kick and bring it in good kick
bring it in again beginner start on the
ground kick it up bring it in
the focus is to really work on your
glutes good kick through your glutes
working bring it in crunch kick good and
act good and act okay want to challenge
yourself with your knee up in and out
give it find a balance find your
midsection balance yourself to your
thighs working keep going
few more seconds keep yourself stable
last one
and bring it down one final workout
I am absolutely dripping right let's lie
on the ground okay so it's going to be a
hip reach okay
always remember to bring your heels
close to your butt hand by your side
bring your butt up down
do not touch squeeze it in down holy for
two seconds bring it back down hold and
down okay
to make it tougher you know the drill
bring it down point your left feet down
steer your right spot working bring it
back down up down and up keep your knees
close together okay and keep your left
leg in one straight line few more ten
more seconds
do not drop now do not give up right now
we're almost there
we're almost done last five seconds keep
going one last one and I want you to
just relax breathe deeply bring your
heart rate down and just stretch it out
well guess who is going to feel really
sore tomorrow I know I am if this
workout is too easy for you
then challenge yourself to complete
three or four sets okay I want to do is
to do this workout on alternate days for
the next six weeks and combine it with
total body strength training and ultra
cardio I can assure you you will get a
tighter and firmer looking legs spot and
also app so be sure to like this video
share with your friends and subscribe to
my youtube channel for more short and
effective exercises healthy and really
simple recipes and also fitness tips all
the best